What if you could turn this into reality
just by typing a sentence? Hi, I'm Kevin
and Google just released V3, an AI video
generator that turns your imagination
into cinematic quality videos using
nothing more than a simple prompt. In
this video, I'll walk you through
exactly how to use V3, how to write
better prompts, and how to get the most
out of it, even if you're brand new to
AI video tools. Oh, and best of all, you
can use it for free for an entire month.
Let's dive in. So, what is Google V3? V3
is Google's latest AI video generation
model built by DeepMind and it lets you
create cinematic quality videos from
just a text prompt. It understands
things like camera movement, lighting,
and composition. So, the results feel
polished and natural, far beyond most AI
tools. But here's what really sets it
apart. V3 doesn't just generate video.
It also adds audio automatically. Like
here in this example,
I'm one with nature now.
Nature would prefer some personal space.
That includes background music, ambient
sound effects, and even voice narration
if you wanted to speak specific lines of
text. And honestly, it looks darn good.
To use V3, you need a paid plan. The
good news though, you can try it for
free for the first month, giving you a
chance to see everything that V3 is
capable of. You can explore the
available plans using the link right
down below on the screen. Both plans
include access to V3. In addition to AI
video generation, you also get access to
things like Gemini and Gmail Docs and
more. Plus, you also get 2 TB of storage
for your Google Photos, Drive, and
email. All in all, it's a solid deal and
pretty much in line with what other
companies are charging for their AI
tools. Once you've signed up for a plan,
head over to the address at the bottom
of the screen and then sign in with your
Google account. This drops us into the
Gemini chat interface and at the bottom
of the screen, you'll see the prompt
field along with a few different tools.
Let's click on the one titled video and
that turns on V3. From there, you could
start typing in your prompt. Let's try
one. A cinematic slow motion shot of
freshly baked chocolate chip cookies
being pulled out of the oven. Then you
could also offer information like where
is it here? I want it to be in a cozy
sunlit kitchen. You could also talk
about the lighting. I want it to be
warm, what the focus should look like,
any atmospheric effects like steam
rising. And also if you want to include
any music. The more details you provide,
the closer the resulting video will
match what you had in mind. Once you're
done entering in your prompt in the
bottom right, let's submit that. Let's
now watch how it turned out.
Oh, overall that's really impressive. I
did notice a few issues. For example,
for whatever reason, some of the
chocolate chips completely melted on top
of the cookie, but overall it matches my
prompt really closely. I'm really
impressed. One cool feature of V3 is
that it doesn't just generate video. It
can also add narration. If you wanted to
speak specific lines of text, just
include that text in quotes as part of
your prompt. Right here, I'll type in my
prompt. And at the very end, I call out
that this is the narration. And then
here, I have all the text that I wanted
to narrate included in quotes. Once you
enter that in as part of your prompt,
let's submit that. Let's preview how
this turned out. History is being made.
The Kevin Cookie Company unveils the
world's largest chocolate chip cookie.
That voice really fits the part. Once
you're satisfied with the way your video
turned out, it's really easy to
download. Simply hover over your video.
Then in the top right hand corner,
you'll see this download icon. Simply
click on that and it'll download an MP4
file onto your computer. And that's it.
You're ready to use your AI generated
video wherever you want. One really
helpful trick when you're not sure how
to phrase your V3 prompt is to just ask
Gemini. Since V3 lives right inside
Gemini, you can use the same chat to
help you refine or improve your ideas
before you generate the video. Now,
let's say I want to make a video about
the Kevin Cookie Company baking the
world's largest chocolate chip cookie,
but I'm not quite sure how to word it to
get that cinematic storybook vibe. Right
down below, I could simply ask Gemini.
So, here I can type in, "Can you help me
write a cinematic video prompt about a
team of bakers making the world's
largest cookie?" Then, let's submit
that. Right up above, Gemini suggests a
much more descriptive version. It
includes things like the camera angles,
the lighting, the background music, even
the pacing. Now, here I could take this
as it is, and I could paste it into the
prompt field, and then I can make tweaks
to it to match exactly what I'm looking
for. If we scroll down a little bit
more, here I have another option. So, I
could look through that to see if maybe
this is a better fit. And all the way
down at the bottom, I even have tips on
the types of things to include in my
prompts to get the best results. So, if
you're ever stuck or you just want your
prompt to sound more epic, just let
Gemini do all the heavy lifting. If you
ever want to go back and watch a video
that you generated earlier, it's super
easy. Just look over on the lefth hand
side of the Gemini interface under
recent. And here you'll see a list of
all of your past chats. Here, I could
click into any one of them and I see the
associated video with that chat. And
just like that, we've officially baked
the world's largest chocolate chip
cookie.
Or did we? What's real and what's not?
Can we even tell anymore? How do you
know this video is real? Don't I mean,
don't worry. I'm not generated by V3. At
least I don't think I am. How can I
prove it? Oh, this face is way too good
to be generated by AI. This is the best
cookie I've ever sampled. Flavor,
texture, everything is perfect.
Everyone agrees Kevin Cookie Company
cookies are the best in the world.
Thousands are lining up for a taste of
cookie greatness.
[Applause]